the freedom convoy truckers are
continuing to stand up to justin
trudeau's vaccine mandates despite a
major crackdown on their protest the
canadian government has already invoked
the emergencies act suspending the
ordinary rule of law suppressing
peaceful protests prohibiting travel and
even freezing the bank accounts of
freedom convoy protesters and their
supporters
but even those extraordinary measures
have not worked to stop the freedom
convoy from honking for their rights and
way of life so the canadian government
has ratcheted up the authoritarianism
even further
by threatening to kill the protesters
puppies
yes yesterday the ottawa bylaw services
announced attention animal owners at
demonstration
if you are unable to care for your
animal as a result of enforcement
actions your animal will be placed into
protective care for eight days at your
cost
after eight days if arrangements are not
made your animal will be considered
relinquished
the government will take your puppy
immediately
then it will protect your puppy for
eight days
and then it won't protect your puppy
anymore
now i am no scientist i do not have
fancy advanced degrees but i am having a
hard time understanding how following
the science and flattening the curve or
whatever requires governments to suspend
the rule of law steal dissidents money
and kill their pets
as we enter day 704
of 15 days to slow the spread after two
years of lies and incompetence every
single step of the way
i'm beginning to think that this is not
about science at all
but rather about the arbitrary
consolidation and exercise of power
which will never ever end unless we
exercise what little political power we
have left and end it ourselves did you
like that clip i hope you liked that
clip if you did leave me a comment just
say hey michael i you know i enjoyed
that that was nice i like your hair
today that's a lovely sweater you got to
subscribe you got to ring that bell get
all the notifications for the next
videos and maybe let's say you're not
getting the notifications for whatever
reason youtube head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you